so um the kazushi geometry so what
what's happening to you is you're doing
the technique you're doing EO you're
doing
uh uh and because the way we are when we
start training we just learning
techniques and you're doing the
technique but you want to do the
concepts the concept you do the concepts
coincidentally the technique manifest as
opposed to I'm going to do the technique
it's a totally different way of looking
at it so we know uh in that we're going
to be using the front award kazushi so
that means that I have to start this
fight uh
rotating this
way such that I get a tilt on his body
of any
proportion in which centrifugal energy
is pulling outward on it and I am
using I key to generate a centri energy
that's what generates the cental energy
and then I project the
center perpendicular to the axis of the
Spiral that I just
created you guys get that that's what
you do every time so I'm not going to go
over
here and then
push straight on that
180 you guys see that that's it looks
like the technique but it's not the
technique so you're
here and you're just accelerating that
way that's not what we're
doing you're going to start this thing
rotating this is why I'm moving this way
you see his head came this way and then
this hand projects to the center at that
angle
okay and you see his body's in a
different
place same thing on the Pama we're doing
okay as I'm here we pay attention what
I'm doing here here he touched the attmy
so I'm using that hand here inside the
grip I'm using the grip and you can see
his head is now moving towards me ever
so slightly it's not on the 180 it's
moving towards me
me there's the spiral and then the
projection through the center and you're
just doing that
time this is different
there's less reaction in it because
there's less forces working on his basis
for
okay bring it in you make sure his head
comes off that 126 line it's indicative
of the
Spiral which is indicative of the
centrifugal cental energies that work
which now gives me my Axis at which I
perpendic project his
Center across okay all right fine right
let's do a little iner in here
um so as the guy's coming in he' have
this hand so as he's coming in and I'm
starting this spiral that we just talked
about okay and then I'm going to project
on this now here's what happens to to
the UK
who has is still not does not know how
to reconcile the ego tripartite mind
they have a pattern in their
head and that pattern tells
them that that knee is going to be
there and this center of gravity is
going to
rotate along the radius it is on now so
they all picture that it just rolls out
out from
here they have in their mind where their
center of gravity is going to
go the problem that comes up is when I'm
projecting that you're going to on that
line that I told you right the
perpendicular line to the axis rotation
of the
Spiral it's not that radius is going to
lengthen so he doesn't get to to go
right
there there'll be even if it's just an
inch there'll be
some movement of the center across the
sagittal plane on that one I think it
was about 4 in okay do do you guys see
that all right
so because the ego Tri parti mind is
afraid it seeks control in its will
power it feels the projection coming in
and they will start hyper Yin yielding
there do you see and then they're trying
to get it to have the same radius that
they
desire all
right and that is more the case when you
guys are doing this one The Chew done
cuz the elbow is bent and they can bend
you see and now you have that hyper Yin
yield where he's open to
EDI uhi everything and that would be
what you would do in real life on a
hyper yield
okay but in the K he needs to create the
reason behind I'm going to go to the arm
meaning I'm not going to go to the EDI
and the
atmi and so he can't hyperal for me to
do the
Wasa so make sure you're understanding I
go here he feels his Center to be
projected he hyper heels you see this is
not where I would go for a
k you see because I I have Ed meat and
now I'm vulnerable to the grin grabs and
all that kind of stuff because I Clos
without my weapons between him and I so
he can grab my GR
you see he starts to fall over he'll
grab it you can fall over it falls this
way so as he as he hyper Yin yields
right your weapons have to stay in front
of you for you to enter this is where
you are here okay now you can
do the things you want to do without
making it vulnerable all right but you
are prescribed in this class
to do this technique I don't want you
doing this technique on this this is not
where this technique happens this
technique
happens here with this arm between us
you see and vulnerable to the
Trap so what I want you to do is as you
more skilled people feel that fear and
he's going to hyper yield you see that I
want you to change and adapt your
C so what I mean is from
here as I
go into that Center do you do you feel
that okay as he starts to I'm going to
do it here where you watch his center
it's going to go into his Center you can
even it's going to go into the
center and now as he starts to
bend that arm you just have to follow
this
hand just follow the hand and you're
back into
it if he starts to hyper yield and you
were on here that's what causes that but
as you start to go you'll feel very much
Y and you just follow it up while still
pressing
forward Hyperion yields doesn't matter
I bring your yields doesn't matter the
arm is back where I want
it guys you understand
that so you're doing it don't do this
don't do that you're going to get caught
in the arms you're going to miss the
center and you won't have that center of
gravity Sally
project across the KN which is what you
want okay
try think go up